'80s nostalgia is in the air, so no wonder
the ninth season of American Horror Story
is taking place smack dab in the middle of
that decade.
But how will AHS 1984 fit into the show's
ever-expanding canon?
Here's everything we know so far.
Leave it to AHS co-creator Ryan Murphy to
blend '80s camp with the menacing undertones
of a slasher film - and all set to the kicky
tune of Dan Hartman's "I Can Dream About You."
Back in July 2019, Murphy made the official
cast announcement on Instagram through a series
of stylish videos staged to look like "camera
tests."
As you can see, everyone is decked out in
their most ill-advised '80s fashions.
Hard to say whether this is what the cast
will actually look like throughout the coming
season.
They could just be toying with our expectations
here.
Meanwhile, the official teaser trailers heavily
draw from slasher-film archetypes and scenarios.
In one teaser, we see a truck full of youngsters
on their way to Camp Redwood.
They're partying so hard they fail to see
the word "BEWARE" scrawled in red paint on
the back of the "Camp Redwood" sign.
Meanwhile, a masked man with a knife is hiding
in the undercarriage.
This guy really gets around: He later jumps
out of a lake in order to stab a bikini-clad
woman - basically a straight-up homage to
the first Friday the 13th.
In another teaser, a young woman is chased
through the dark woods.
She hides in a cabin, and soon enough, a knife
comes through the door.
Yet another teaser features a group of camp
counselors settling into their bunks.
And when the cabin door closes?
Another teaser demonstrates the dangers of
skinny dipping:
“ah”
And this teaser is an ode to the simple pleasures
like listening to your Walkman, and getting
brutally murdered.
“ah”
Our theory?
This season is going to be a whole lot of
fun.
As with previous seasons of American Horror
Story, Ryan Murphy has assembled a mix of
new and returning cast members to play all-new
characters, this time in 1984.
Returning stars include Cody Fern, Billie
Lourd, Emma Roberts, Leslie Grossman, and
a decidedly creepy John Carroll Lynch.
We're particularly loving Cody Fern as an
'80s-style preppy dude... especially since
he looks a bit like James Spader in Pretty
in Pink.
Newcomers include Olympic skier Gus Kenworthy,
Glee alum Matthew Morrison, Angelica Ross
from the hit series Pose, Dear White People's
DeRon Horton, and actor and musician Zach
Villa.
Unfortunately, AHS 1984 will be losing some
of the series' most beloved cast members,
too.
You know how that goes.
"What is this?
Knotty pine!"
Of course, Jessica Lange left the show as
a regular player after the fourth season,
Freak Show… and now two more regulars are
following in her footsteps.
Sadly, Evan Peters won't be returning this
season.
Due to the intensity of his roles in both
American Horror Story and Ryan Murphy's Pose,
he decided to take a break.
Meanwhile, Sarah Paulson won't be returning
to the show in any significant role, although
Deadline reports we can expect to see her
at some point in the season.
With any luck, she'll pop up in a cameo like
Lange did in Season 8.
In the upcoming season of AHS, '80s nostalgia
in clearly in full bloom, so it might be worth
revisiting some seminal horror films from
1984 - just in case Ryan Murphy has decided
to use them for inspiration.
1984 was a big year for the horror genre.
After all, that was the year A Nightmare on
Elm Street was released.
"Hey, Nancy… no running in the hallways."
Then there was Friday the 13th: The Final
Chapter.
And who can forget Children of the Corn?
"Stop him!
Kill him!"
"MALACHAI!"
Also worth noting: Firestarter came out in
1984, and so did Brian DePalma's campy psychological
thriller Body Double.
Both films certainly align with Murphy's unique
brand of horror.
Then again, longtime AHS executive producer
Tim Minear reminds us to expect the unexpected.
TheWrap asked whether this season would be
revisiting '80s horror films, and he replied:
"Generally, Ryan is ahead of the zeitgeist
as opposed to following it.
So what I would say is that this has been
an area that Ryan has talked about since I’ve
known him and it’s just a real sweet spot
for him.
And I think it was time for him to do it."
So what's the story?
It looks like AHS 1984 is going to be a beautiful,
gory, and funny homage to the slasher films
of the '80s.
But this is a Ryan Murphy production, so you
can probably expect some social and political
subtext, too.
After all, the year 1984 corresponds to George
Orwell's dystopian novel of the same name.
Just sayin'.
One more thing: The use of The Motel's classic
single "Suddenly Last Summer" in the "Camp
Redwood" teaser could be a clue to the plotline.
After all, Suddenly, Last Summer is a classic
1958 play written by Tennessee Williams.
It was later adapted into a film starring
Elizabeth Taylor.
The story involves a woman named Catharine
who's traumatized after witnessing her cousin's
death.
Her aunt - played by Katherine Hepburn - attempts
to keep her son's death a secret by lobotomizing
her niece.
It's some pretty melodramatic stuff.
"I ran, they let me run, they didn't even
see me…"
It also covers subject matter that's up this
series' alley, and we wouldn't be at all surprised
if the show pays homage to Suddenly, Last
Summer in AHS 1984.
The ninth season of American Horror Story
premieres on September 18th, 2019 at 10pm
Eastern time.
The season will have a ten-episode run, with
the seventh episode set to air on October
30th… which just so happens to be Halloween
Eve.
How terribly apropos.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.